OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
BRING.
THIS HEARING. TO ORDER AND
SERGEANTS IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
NOTIFY THE OTHER.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS BEGUN
[inaudible]
IN AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTEEN
GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACTS BETWEEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE BIG VALLEY BAND OF POMO
INDIANS OF THE BIG VALLEY
RANCHERIA THE TOROS MARTINEZ
BAND OF DESERT QUE INDIANS.
THE MATURE PETER INDIAN TRIBE OF
CHICO RANCHER RANCHERIA AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS TWENTY NINE PALM BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS.
AS WELL AS AMENDMENTS TO CURL
TRUCK CURRENT TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACTS.
THE HOME BULL POLO OF UPPER LAKE
IN THE SENATE AS BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS.
THE ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEES WERE
FILLING HIS RESPONSIBILITIES
AFTERNOON BY.
HOLDING AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON THE SPECIFICS OF THESE NEW
COMPACTS OR COMPACT AMENDMENTS.
NO FORMAL VOTE WILL BE TAKEN --
AS CONTACT NUMBER CANNOT BE
AMENDED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AT A LATER DATE EACH OF THESE
COMPACTS WILL BE TAKEN UP FOR
CONSIDERATION BY THE ENTIRE BODY
A FORMAL VOTE ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
TODAY WE WERE HERE FOR THE
PRINCIPAL ARCHITECTS OF THESE
COMPACTS THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THE TRIBES THEMSELVES.
THE COMPACT WITH THE BIG VALLEY
BAND IN THE TOWARDS MARTINEZ
BAND FURTHER THE PARTY'S MUTUAL
INTEREST IN IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE.
OF TRIBAL MEMBERS TO A FRAMEWORK
THAT GENERATES REVENUE FOR
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS WHILE
ALSO FAIRLY REGULATING GAMING
ACTIVITIES.
AFFORDING MEANINGFUL CONSUMER
EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS AND
MITIGATING DE OFF RESERVATION
IMPACTS OF THE GAMING FACILITY.
ONCE EFFECTIVE THESE CONTACTS
WILL BE IN FULL FORCE AND EFFECT
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOLLOWING.
THE EFFECTIVE DATE [inaudible]
THE COMPACTS THE SAN PASQUAL
MANDATORY NINE PALMS BEEN
INCLUDE UPDATED PROVISIONS FOR
LICENSING COMPLIANCE ENFORCEMENT
MITIGATION ABOUT PRESERVATION
IMPACTS THE REGULATORY
PROVISIONS RESPECT THE AUTHORITY
OF EACH TRIBES PROFESSIONAL
REGULATORS.
AND BUILD UPON THEIR
CONSTRUCTIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE STATE GAMING REGULATORY.
THE TERMS OF EACH COMPAQ REFLECT
THE TRIBES SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES AND MARKETS IN
WHICH EACH TRIBE OPERATES ITS
GAMING FACILITY.
ONCE AFFECTED AGAIN IS COMPAQ'S
WILL BE IN FULL FORCE FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS FOLLOWING THE
EFFECTIVE DATE.
THE CORE PROVISIONS.
INCLUDE TERMS LATER REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH
SAFETY ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AND MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
INVESTMENTS AND LOCAL COMMUNITY.
AS WELL AS REVENUE SHARING.
THESE ARE SIMILAR TO A
PROVISIONS WE FOUND RECENT
COMPAQ'S MEMBERS THE TERMS ARE
INTENDED TO PROVIDE THE TRIBE
THE FLEXIBILITY DEVELOPING NEW
GAMING FACILITY THAT GENERATES
REVENUE FOR TRIBAL GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS.
WHILE ENSURING THAT IMPACTS ON
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
APPROPRIATELY MITIGATED.
AGAIN --
THESE CONTACTS WILL BE IN FULL
FORCE TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOR THE
EFFECTIVE DATE.
THE OTHER MAJOR COMPONENTS OF
THESE COMPACTS ARE SIGNIFICANT
SIMILAR OR IDENTICAL TO THOSE
FOUND IN ALL THE COMPACTS
RATIFIED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVEN TEAM AS IT RELATES
TO LOCAL MITIGATION LABOR
PROVISIONS HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
WORKERS COMPENSATION PATRON
DISPUTES PROGRAMS TO MITIGATE
PROBLEM GAMBLING.
ON THE AMENDED COMPACT WITH THE
UPPER LAKE TRIBE CONFORMS TO
PROVISIONS OF ITS TWENTY ELEVEN
COMPACT REGARDING WORKERS
COMPENSATION LABOR RELATIONS TO
THOSE.
OF MORE RECENT COMPAQ'S.
THE AMENDMENT TO THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN COMPACT WITH THE SENATE
AS BAND AUTHORIZES OFF TRACK
WAGERING ON HORSE RACES AT A
SATELLITE WAGERING FACILITY WITH
DAN.
DE EXISTING GAMING FACILITY.
AYE LAST MISTER DILLON TO TOUCH
ON THE SPECIFIC FINANCIAL TERMS
OF THESE COMPAQ'S.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES IN ADVANCE FOR TAKING
THE TIME OUT OF THEIR BUSY
SCHEDULES TO BE WITH US TODAY.
AND WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WILL
BEGIN THE HEARING --
DO WE HAVE MISTER DILLON
[inaudible]
PRESIDENT.
OKAY WILL BEGIN WITH BIG VALLEY
.
WELCOME FIRST BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN WITH YOUR OVERVIEW
--
AND THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
TRIBE AND SPECIAL GAS MISTER
JACK RUBY --
YES SIR THANK YOU CHAIRMAN --
MEMBERS OF THE COMPACT WITH --
BIG VALLEY --
AUTHORIZES THAT RIGHT TO GAMING
FACILITIES IN UP TO TWELVE
HUNDRED SLOT MACHINES OF THE
TRIBE CURRENTLY OPERATES UNDER
--
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE TROUBLE
STATE GAMING COMPACT THEIR
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND.
ELIGIBLE TRIBE DIFFERENTLY
OPERATING LESS THAN THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SLOTS.
BUT UNDER THE TERMS OF THE
NINETY NINE COMPAQ THEY STILL
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO PAY STF IN
AND THERE WAS A TIME TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAD THE ABILITY TO
GROW THAT THEY HAD TO PAY
LICENSE FEES.
UP PURSUANT TO THE TERMS THAT
NINETY NINE COMPAQ.
WHICH REFLECTED CERTAIN
ASSUMPTIONS AT THAT TIME ABOUT
--
WHO SHOULD PAY INTO THE STF IN
AND HOW ARE STIFF WAS FUNDED
WE'VE TRIED TO IN OUR RECENT
NEGOTIATIONS --
COME UP WITH A MORE SUSTAINABLE
A FRAMEWORK BASED ON THE ABILITY
OF IT -- OF
A TRIBE TO TO CONTRIBUTE TO ON
THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND
TRIBAL NATION GRANDSON.
OF AND ENSURE THAT IT'S FAIR TO
THE TRIBES THAT CONTRIBUTE AS
WELL AS TO THOSE THAT RECEIVE SO
UNDER THIS FRAMEWORK THE TRIBE.
I WOULDN'T HAVE TO MAKE ANY
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND TRIBAL NATION
GRANDSON THROUGH THE
NEGOTIATIONS.
WITH OTHER TRIBES --
WE BELIEVE THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE
NOT GOOD TO PROVIDE THE BENEFITS
THEY DO TO THE SEVENTY TWO RCF
ELIGIBLE TRIBES --
IN ADDITION EVEN THOUGH THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN A COMPACT --
PROVIDES FOR A PRO RATA SHARE
PAYMENT TO THE INDIAN GAMING
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND TO
COVER THE STATE'S REGULATORY
COSTS IN PROBLEM GAMBLING --
BUDGET LANGUAGE THIS YEAR
AUTHORIZES THE STATE TO REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE ANY OBLIGATION THE
TRIBE WOULD HAVE TO PAY.
TIME TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
ARE FUNDS AVAILABLE TO TO COVER
THOSE COSTS SO WE BELIEVE THAT
--
THIS FURTHERS THE STATE'S
OBJECTIVES ENSURING THAT --
THOSE FUNDS ARE ARE ARE SOLVENT
IN IN --
MEETING THEIR OBJECTIVES AND IT
ACTUALLY REDUCES THE TRIBES
OBLIGATIONS SIGNIFICANTLY TO
MAKE PAYMENTS.
THAT WITH THAT'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR TRADE
OVER -- TO
THE TROUBLE TREASURE.
MANY WITHOUT CARLA RODRIGUEZ AND
I'M FROM THE BIG VALLEY
RANCHERIA VANNA PUMMELING IN
SIAM DAY ELECTED --
TRIBAL COUNCIL TREASURE.
AND I COME FROM A TRIBE OF ABOUT
ELEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS THAT SIX
HUNDRED EIGHT VOTING --
ADULTS OVER TWENTY ONE AND THE
RESEARCH CHILDREN.
SO -- YOU
KNOW THE GAMING REVENUE IS --
SUBSTANTIAL FOR AT THE HOT
CONTINUED OPERATION FOR A TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT --
ALSO TO SUPPORT THE TRIBAL
MEMBERS SUCH AS HIGHER EDUCATION
BENEFITS --
HOUSING --
YOU KNOW JUST JUST STAR.
REMODELING AND AND UPDATING OF
OF OLD EXISTING HOUSING THAT WE
HAVE OUT THERE SO --
AGAIN A SISSY OVER HERE TOO I'M
HERE TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
YOU KNOW GETTING OUR CONTACT
RATIFIED AND APPROVED.
MR GROUP UP MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACK ROBIN I
REPRESENT UNITE HERE THE HOTEL
AND CASINO WORKERS UNION.
WE SUPPORT THE BIG VALLEY BAND
OF POMO INDIANS ARE COMPACT
AMENDMENT.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT WE WANT
TO SAY SINCE THIS IS PROBABLY
THE LAST YOU KNOW HEARING FOR
THE THIS SESSION --
THAT WORKING WITH --
THIS GOVERNOR --
AND THE GEO COMMITTEES IN BOTH
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY --
AS WELL AS JOE DILLON --
AS THE LEAD ON THIS ISSUE FEEL
THAT AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF VERY
VERY GOOD WORK HAS BEEN DONE.
AND JUST TO PUT A PERIOD ON THAT
PARAGRAPH IS THAT.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND WORKERS IN THE TRIBAL
GAMING INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO NEGOTIATE DIRECTLY WITH
THEIR EMPLOYERS OVER THE ISSUE
OF WAGES AND BENEFITS AND
WORKING CONDITIONS SO THESE
AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
OVER THE YEARS HAVE NOT ONLY?
LIFTED THE TRIBES UP OUT OF
POVERTY [inaudible]
IT'S LIFTED.
QUITE A FEW THOUSAND WORKERS UP
AT A POVERTY AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT IS A TOTAL POSITIVE OUTCOME
FOR THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY
SINCE ATRASO.
WE JUST WANT TO SAY AT THE END
OF THE JERRY BROWN
ADMINISTRATION THE END OF EACH
OF JAIL AND HIS.
THE NEGOTIATOR FOR THESE
COMPACTS THAT.
WE'RE WE'RE VERY VERY HAPPY AT
THE WAY EVERYBODY'S BEEN BROUGHT
TO THE TABLE AND BEEN DEALT WITH
APPROPRIATELY.
AND RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY NEON.
QUESTIONS FOR OUR WITNESSES FROM
MEMBERS.
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT ANY
--
TESTIMONY --
IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATION'S INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU TO OUR WITNESSES OUR
CONGRATULATIONS CENTER ON YOUR
EFFORTS THUS FAR AND AGAIN WE
WILL SEE --
THIS COMPACT ARMY --
FOR FOR A VOTE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE.
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE
GONNA MOVE TO THE UPPER LAKE
COMPACT AMER GONNA.
ASK --
CHAIRWOMAN ATTEMPTED TO JOIN US
--
APPEAR AT THE DYESS --
JOE DO YOU DEL AND YOU WONDER
WHY GIVE US.
THE OVERVIEW YES SIR A REAL
BRIEF -- THE
AMENDMENT A MAN'S THE TRIBES --
IN TWO WAYS IT --
CONFORMS THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION PROVISIONS AS TO
THOSE OF RECENT COMPACTS --
ESSENTIALLY GIVES THE TRIBE AN
OPTION IT CAN.
SPIN THE STATE SYSTEM OR A
CONTENT OF A COMPARABLE SYSTEM
THAT PROVIDES THE SAME.
RIGHTS AND BENEFITS --
TO TO EMPLOYEES IN ADDITION IT
ADVANCE THE TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDER SO I THINK THE
TRIBE IS A LONG STANDING.
A POSITIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH
LABOR BUT THIS JUST A MAN'S THE
ATTILA ROW IN IN THE COMPACT --
AND CONFORMS IT WITH A RECENT --
WORK [inaudible]
JUROR.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SHERRI TRAP
I'M THE CHAIRWOMAN OF HEAVY
METAL POMO OF UPPER LAKE TRIBE
WE RESIDE IN THE AREA NOW UPPER
LAKE CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY WERE HIGHLY
IMPACTED BY THE RECENT FIRES --
NOT ONLY OUR TRY BUT THE
COMMUNITIES OF THANKS FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MY
TRIBE TODAY LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
THE OTHER ACCOUNTS MEMBER IN THE
AUDIENCE.
OF VICE CHAIR UP PERSON TRAPPED
AS WELL --
JUST GIVE A HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE OUR TRIBE WAS
TERMINATED IN THE FIFTIES AND
RESTORED IN THE EIGHTIES --
FROM THAT POINT WE WERE LAND --
LOOSELY ORGANIZED INTO TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WHEN WE HAD OUR
CONSTITUTION PASSED WE FORGED A
VERY.
POSITIVE GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP EARLY ON
WITH OUR COMMUNITY AND WHICH
ENABLED US --
TO ENTER INTO COUPLE OF AMMO
USED NOT ONLY WITH LAKE COUNTY
BUT ALSO WITH NORTH SHORE FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE SOME SUPPORT LETTERS
FROM THEM AS WELL --
DURING THE RECENT FIRES WE WERE
FORTUNATELY ABLE TO CONTINUE.
TO PAGE --
THE EMPLOYEES A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY OF OUR GAMING OPERATION AS
WELL AS ANOTHER FIFTY THAT WE
HAVE EMPLOYED ELSEWHERE WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY --
WE ARE HERE TODAY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
THIS COMPACT MOVE QUICKLY
THROUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS I
THINK YOU ARTICULATED FAIRLY
WELL WHAT WE WERE --
ASKING FOR TODAY AND AND WE'D
LIKE TO THINK OF THE STATE FOR
WORKING WITH US TO MAKE THIS
AMENDMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AGAIN JACK RABBIT WITH UNITE
HERE --
WE'VE WORKED WELL WITH THE UPPER
LEG TRIED FOR YEARS AND WE'RE
JUST BACK HERE SUPPORTING THEIR
COMPACT AGAIN THEIR COMPACT
AMENDMENT.
OKAY IN THE QUESTIONS TO THE
MEMBERS FOR THE WITNESSES.
SEEING NONE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
SUSAN JENSEN ON BEHALF OF CA
NINETY AND SUPPORT.
CHRIS LINDSTROM CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL BUSINESS ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SPORT.
OKAY SEEING NO.
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU
TO OUR WITNESSES OUR
CONGRATULATIONS ON ARE.
MOVING THIS PHARMACY THIS ON THE
FOR FOR VOTE.
I IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE GONNA
MOVE TO THE MIX CHUPA TRIBE --
COMPACT AND WILL ASK MISTER
DILLON TO COVER AGAIN PROBABLY
DE AT KEY PROVISIONS THAT ARE
DIFFERENT --
IN THE COMPACT AND FOR THE SAKE
OF TIME AND YES SIR THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ADMIT YOU PUT --
COMPACT --
AUTHORIZED TO TRY TO OPERATE UP
TO TWO FACILITIES IN --
TWO THOUSAND SLOT MACHINES.
PRIOR TO IN OF ANY FACILITY THEY
AS YOU'D INDICATED NEED TO GO
THROUGH THE SAME.
PROCESS FOR THE GUARD
IDENTIFICATION AND AND
MITIGATION ABOUT PRESERVATION
IMPACTS --
WITH REGARD TO THAT --
THE ECONOMICS AND BECAUSE THIS
IS A NEW FACILITY JUST AS WE'VE
DONE IN SOME OF OUR RECENT
COMPAQ SUCH AS WILTON ARE MOULE
WE'VE --
RECOGNIZE THE TRIBE DOES HAVE
SOME SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO
DO WITH YOU WITH REGARD TO
GETTING THE FACILITY UP AND OFF
THE GROUND IN ADDRESSING TO THE
NEEDS OF AT THE MEMBERS IN THE
TRIBAL PROGRAMS.
SAID THAT --
THE OBLIGATION TO PAY INTO THE
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND --
ONLY KICKS IN IF THEY GO ABOVE A
TWELVE HUNDRED AND DOESN'T KICK
IN FOR THE FIRST SEVEN YEARS OF
OPERATION.
IN ADDITION --
THE COMPACT AUTHORIZES THE TRIBE
TO REDUCE THOSE PAYMENTS BY UP
270% OF FOR THE SAME KINDS OF
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL INVESTMENTS
IN THE FORM OF CREDITS THAT ARE
SPECIFIED IN THE COMPACT AGAIN
TO BENEFIT TRIBAL MEMBERS AND
ALSO. TO TO DEMONSTRATE THE
BENEFIT THAT --
TRIBAL GAMING IS HAVING WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY.
CHAIRMAN REPAIRS.
THANK YOU.
MULTIPLE CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY --
I'M HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
WITH A COUPLE OF YOU AND IT WAS
A PLEASURE TO DO THAT THAT DAY I
KNOW YOU'RE BUSY SCHEDULES OF MY
THANK YOU FOR THAT --
I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE A VICE
CHAIR WHEN.
IS HERE WITH EIGHT ME TODAY AND
I AM --
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO TO GET THIS
--
UP AND RUNNING FOR FOR MANY
YEARS OVER SIXTEEN YEARS OF
LITIGATION A SINCE --
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND
GOVERNMENT DIDN'T FIGHT AND NOW
BAND BICU COUNTY HAS.
COME ABOARD TO AND WANT TO WORK
WITH US NOW SO WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THAT TO TO MOVE FORWARD
AND NOW.
AND AND GET THIS UP AND RUNNING
ARE MAIN GOAL IS SO AS TO HELP
THE COMMUNITY --
OUR TRIBAL COMMUNITY AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES AND YOU
COUNTY -- WE
DO HAVE SMALL PROGRAMS FOR
EDUCATION FOR OUR KIDS --
HIGHER EDUCATION --
FOR TO HELP PAY FOR THEIR
SCHOOLING AND VOCATIONAL
SCHOOLING.
WELL WE WANT TO DEFTLY TAKE CARE
OF OUR ELDERS THAT'S ALWAYS A
MAIN THING IN ANY COUNTRY IS OUR
ELDERS ARE DEATHLY TAKE CARE.
SO WE WON'T BE ABLE TO HAVE
THOSE FINANCES THAT WHAT LITTLE
WE HAVE TO INCREASE THAT TO MAKE
SURE OUR ELDERS ARE TAKEN CARE
--
THEY'RE PASSING AS WE SPEAK IN
AND IT'S SAD THAT --
THEY DON'T GET TO SEE THIS SO
WE'RE DEFINITELY LOOKING FORWARD
TO THEM.
GETTING THIS UP AND RUNNING AND
WITH YOUR CONSIDERATION WORK
WE'RE GRATEFUL SO I THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JACOBIN
AGAIN WITH UNITE HERE AND WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE MAKE SHIFT
--
COMPACT AMENDMENT.
OKAY ANY --
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERSHIP
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF SEEN
IDEA IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMPAQ.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WAS DEALT THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN NO THANK YOU.
DIFFICULT ISSUES IN TIME
OVERCOME CONGRATULATIONS ON NOT
BEING BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
GOOD COUNSEL WE DEFINITELY WANT
TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT AND WE WE
STUCK IT OUT TO THEM.
BECAUSE OUR GOAL IS TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR MEMBERS AND OUR MEMBERS
QUIPPED TRUST IN US AND AND IT'S
FUNNY WORKING OUT. TO TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING.
TO WE HAVE TO THE SAN PASQUAL
BAND.
PUBLISHED IN A COMPACT.
MISTER DILLON.
QUICK PRESENTATION AND THEN WE
WILL HEAR FROM OUR JUNE OF RO.
ARE BEHALF TRUCK YES SIR THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN --
SAMPRAS QUALLS LOCATED IN NORTH
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND ACTUALLY
DANCE COMPETITIVE MARKET VOTE
FOR TRIBAL GAMING THEY CURRENTLY
OPERATE CLOSE --
TO TWO THOUSAND SLOTS THIS
GROWTH OF UP --
TO TWENTY TO FIFTY AND SIMILAR
TO OTHER --
COMPACTS THAT WE'VE DONE WITHIN
ANY COUNTY BASIS THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS --
TO TO THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST
FUND TRIBAL NATION BRAIN.
GRANT FUND BASED ON GROSS GAMING
REVENUE UP BECAUSE THAT --
DEFINITION IS MORE INCLUSIVE IT
DOESN'T INCLUDE FREEPLAY BUT IT
DOES INCLUDE THINGS THAT AREN'T
INCLUDED IN THAT WHEN THE
PERCENTAGE IS ACTUALLY 4% RATHER
THAN -- A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE FOR A TRIED
PAYING BASED ON THAT NGUYEN --
THOSE THE ECONOMICS THAT IN
ADDITION THIS THIS TRIBE THE COP
AND ALLOWS --
REDUCTION FOR THE SAME KINDS OF
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL INVESTMENT
SEPARATE 65% OF THAT PAYMENT
OBLIGATION CAN BE REDUCED
THROUGH THE CREDITS OF
FURTHERING THE OUTSTANDING
RELATIONSHIP THAT THE TRIBE HAS
WITH.
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AND LOCAL
JUST [inaudible]
YOU ARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GRAY.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ON MY NAME IS JOE NAVARRO IMA
TRIBAL MEMBER WITH SANTA SCHOOL
BAND.
AND I AM THE ELECTED PRESIDENT
AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE TRIBES --
GAMING CORPORATION.
AND I HAVE A BRIEF PREPARED
STATEMENT.
OF FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
JOE DILLON SHARED DRAKE.
AND JENNIFER HENDERSON AND THEIR
ENTIRE TEAM FOR THEIR
PROFESSIONALISM AND
COLLABORATION WORKING TOWARDS
COMPACT THAT IS FAIR TO ALL.
INTERESTED PARTIES INCLUDING
STATE AND OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AGAIN THANK YOU JOE PLEASE PASS
ON OUR GRATITUDE TO SHARON
JENNIFER IN THE TEAM --
AS RELATES TO OUR RESERVATIONS
HAVE SCHOOL RESERVATION AS JOE
MENTIONED IS LOCATED IN THE
HILLS OF NORTHERN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
THEN THE COMMUNITY OF VALLEY
CENTER --
WHERE TRIBE OF HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE MEMBERS --
75% OF WHOM ARE OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY FIVE AND WE ARE CENTRALLY
LOCATED IN THE HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
GAMING MARKET.
OUR NEW COMPACT PROVISIONS WILL
ALLOW THE SAP SCHOOL TRIED TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING FOR ITS
MEMBERS --
AND BENEFIT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR FIRE.
POLICE EDUCATION WATER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL DEPARTMENTS.
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE
STABILITY OF OUR NEW COMP OUR
THAT OUR NEW COMPACT PROVIDES
FOR OUR FUTURE.
AND THE FUTURE OF THE COMMUNITY
AT LARGE AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CERTAINLY WILLING TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
JACK RIBBON WITH UNITE HERE THE
HOTEL CASINO WORKERS UNION --
WE SUPPORT THE SAMPER SQUALL
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS COMPACT
AMENDMENT AND WE WISH THEM THE
BEST SUCCESS.
OKAY ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME.
SHANE ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
AND SPORT.
SUSAN JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF SEEN
IDEA IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS LINDSTROM ARMY HALF THE
PAULA BAND OF MISSION INDIANS IN
SUPPORT.
PRE DOT THE MEMBERSHIP
QUESTIONS.
SEEING THEM CONGRADULATIONS LE
ON YOUR STEPS IN THE PROCESS OF
WILL WILL SEE THIS SITE IN THE
NEXT -- FEW
DAYS ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR FOR A
FORMAL VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO THE SENATE AS BAND
OF MISSION INDIANS AND WE'RE
GONNA ASK --
CHAIRMAN CALM.
TO PLEASE APPROACH AND JOIN US.
THAT DIOXIN MISSION DON'T YOU
WANT TO GIVE US AN INTRO ON THE
ARE COMPACT --
YES SIR --
REAL BRIEF THAT AS YOU'VE
INDICATED IT'S AN OFF TRACK
WAGERING AMENDED TO THE TRIBES
EX. TWENTY FIFTEEN COMPACT --
LE THE TERMS OF THIS ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO THOSE OF OTHER OFF
TRACK WAGERING --
COMPACTS IT ADDS AN APPENDIX TO
THE EXISTING COMPACT THAT
BASICALLY ALLOWS THE TRIBE TO
OFFER THIS FORM OF CLASS THREE
GAMING.
IT IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT IN
TERMS OF A FORM OF GAMING IN
TERMS OF HOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
HORSE RACING BOARD ACTUALLY
REGULATES THIS FACILITY TOGETHER
WITH THE TRIBE BUT IN IN THE
SAME MANNER AND SUBS TO THE SAME
RULES AS ANY OTHER SATELLITE WE
SHOULD FACILITIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO IT'S A BENEFIT TO THE TRIBE
OF THE PATRONS OF THE FACILITY
BY GIVING THEM AN AMENITY AND
GENERATE WEB.
THE TRIBE BUT ALSO EXPANDS THAT
THE REACH OF THE HORSE RACING
INDUSTRY.
AND IN A NEW FACILITY
[inaudible]
CHAIRMAN.
GOOD MATTER GOOD MORNING KEVIN
GRAY AND MEMBERS OF THE BOARD --
MY NAME IS KENNETH CON ON THE
TRIBAL CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
HAS BEEN OF TO MASH INDIANS --
WHEN WE HAD NEW GO SHE HATED ARE
--
CONTACTED --
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE HAD LEFT
IN A PLACE HOLDER FOR FUTURE --
OFF TRACK WAGERING COMPACT --
ALSO KNOWN AS OTB --
SINCE THAT TIME --
OTHER NEW RENEGOTIATED COMPACTS
--
HAVE INCLUDED OTB --
AMENDMENTS AND ATTACHMENTS TO
THEIR CLASS THREE GAMING
COMPACTS.
TODAY WE ASK THAT YOU RATIFY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT TO THE CHUMASH
CLASS THREE GAMING COMPACT IT
ADDS APPENDIX E. TO THE CHUMASH
TROUBLE STATE GAMING COMPACT
PERMIT OFF TRACK WAGERING.
ON HORSE RACES.
AT A SATELLITE WAGERING FACILITY
ON THE SENATE AS CHUMASH INDIAN
RESERVATION.
SUCH AMENDMENT DOES NOT CHANGE
ANY OTHER.
A SUBSTANTIAL TERMS AS SUCH IS
TERM OR NUMBER OF FOR MANY CLASS
THREE GAME DEVICES --
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB THREE TWO SIX TWO TO RATIFY
--
THIS FIRST AMENDMENT OF THE
TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACT
BETWEEN THE TRIBE.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE ALL
THOSE -- IN
SUPPORT AND THAT HAVE WORKED
HARD THIS IS ESPECIALLY A JOE
DEL IN HERE SO THANK YOU.
GOOD MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JACKRABBIT WITH UNITE HERE WE
SUPPORT THE SENDING AS BAND.
CHIU MUCH INDIANS COMPACT
AMENDMENT AS WE SUPPORTED THEIR
COMPACT IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THANK YOU.
OKAY DO WE HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
THIS TIME.
SUSAN JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF SCENE
I GO AND SUPPORT.
SHE DOES NOT HAVE THE TEACHERS
IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS LINDSTROM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL BUSINESS
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
OKAY LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS OF ALL OUR
KICK IT OFF WITH THE QUESTION
FROM THE SHELLING --
NEW EXPLOIT WELCOME OUR SEEKS
WHEN THE HORSE RACING BOARD
RELATIONSHIP IN THIS IN THIS --
TRIALS TO CONDUCT BUT I DOES
THAT A MORE RECENT.
COMPAQ'S OF CONTAIN LANGUAGE ON
THIS -- MORE
FREQUENTLY.
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK IS DRIVING
THE DESIRE TO CONDUCT --
OR YOUR HORSE RACING OPERATE.
YEAH QUICK QUESTION CHAIRMAN I
THINK THAT WE WE DID A COUPLE
PROBABLY IN AND TWENTY DEAN I
THINK AND I'VE DONE A FEW EACH
YEAR I THINK IT'S JUST A WAY FOR
FROM THE TRIBES PERSPECTIVE --
TO EXPAND THE KINDS OF
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY THEY'RE
OFFERING ANY THAT'S ONE WAY TO
EXPAND --
THEIR MARKET POTENTIALLY TO
MAYBE BRING IN NEW PEOPLE OR TO
GIVE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE
SOMETHING ADDITIONAL TO DO --
SO I THINK IT'S JUST A GOOD
BUSINESS DECISION FROM THE
TRIBES PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
INDUSTRY PERSPECTIVE I THINK IT
DID JUST AGAIN --
GIVES -- THE
HORSE RACING INDUSTRY WHICH
CERTAINLY FACES YOU KNOW
CHALLENGES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADD TO TOUCH --
MORE PEOPLE TO TO TO TO CONTINUE
TO STAY VIBRANT AND POTENTIALLY
GROW SO I I THINK IT'S JUST --
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS EXPLAIN YOU
OPPORTUNITIES THAT'S THAT'S LED
US TO SUBJECT TO THE REQUIREMENT
UNDER A GREAT WHICH IF IT'S
CLASS BE GAMING LEGAL IN THE
STATE WE HAVE A DUTY.
NEGOTIATE THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE
DID HEAR THESE THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD I
MEAN REALLY WE BASICALLY TAKE.
EXISTING STATE LA AND PLUG THAT
IN A WAY THAT'S APPROPRIATE WITH
APPROPRIATE AMENDMENTS --
INTO THE COMPACT AS AN APPENDIX
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE DONE HERE AND
WE DO THAT AS WELL I THINK IT.
BUT JOHN GOT PROBABLY SEVEN WELL
I BUT MAYBE.
THE QUESTIONS ARE.
FROM THE MEMBERS.
CONGRADULATIONS A CHAIRMAN YOU
HAVE. ONE OF MY FAVORITE AUTHORS
ON THIS BILL.
AND DOWN I'M SURE YOU'LL DO VERY
WELL ON THE SENATE FLOOR HERE IN
THE COMING DAYS [inaudible]
SOME.
THERE'S WORK AS WELL.
THANK YOU ALL.
OKAY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE TORIES
MARTINEZ BAND --
COMPACT.
I WILL ASK WHICH DOING TO GO
AHEAD WITH HIS COMMENTS AND WILL
WELCOME --
CHAIRMAN --
TORCHES AND I TRIBAL UNLIKE
CONSULTANT BRENDA TO THE DIETS
FOR THEIR COMMENTS AS WELL.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THAT TOWARDS
MARTINEZ --
IT IS LOCATED BOTH RIVERSIDE AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES THE TRIBAL
ADMINISTRATION HEADQUARTERS IS
LOCATED RIVERSIDE COUNTY THE
EXISTING GAMING FACILITY.
IS LOCATED IN IMPERIAL COUNTY
EL.
THE TRIBE IS A REVENUE SHARING
TRUST FUND LG --
PURSUANT TO THEIR TWO THOUSAND
THREE COMPACT MUCH OF THE AT
LEAST A PORTION OF THE MONEY
THAT THEY GET COMES BACK TO THE
STATE THROUGH PAYMENTS TO
ACTUALLY TO THE GENERAL FUND SO.
AGAIN AS WE WORK THROUGH --
ARE COMPACTS I THINK --
WE ARE TRYING TO FILL THE
PURPOSE OF BIG WHICH ENSURE THAT
THE TRIBE IS THE PRIMARY
BENEFICIARY OF TRIBAL GAMING AND
WE SCOTT PECK DOES THAT WITHOUT
UNDERMINING OUR LEGITIMATE
INTERESTS AND OBJECTIVES. TO
ENSURE THAT THE STF IS FUNDED
ARE THAT THAT OTHER TRIBES THAT
DON'T HAVE --
LARGE GAMING FACILITIES.
LIKE THIS ONE ACTUALLY GET GET
BENEFITS SO --
IT'S TWELVE HUNDRED SLOTS TO
FACILITIES THE TRIBE HAS AN
EXISTING FACILITY IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY I THINK THEY'RE LOOKING
AT THE CHAIRMAN WILL INDICATE.
TO BUILD A NEW FACILITY IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY --
THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR TURN IT OVER THE
CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GRAHAM
THAT MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY MY
NAME IS THOMAS TORTOISE JUNIOR
THAT CHAIRMAN. FOR THE TOWARD
MARTINEZ DOES AGREE INDIANS --
LOCATED.
AND IN --
THE RESERVATION CURRENTLY HAS
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND ACRES
ELEVEN THOUSAND ACRES WHICH LIES
UNDER THE SALTON SEA.
SO TODAY WERE URGING THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE OUR
RECENTLY NEGOTIATED TRAVEL STATE
COMPACT AT PRESIDENT DE TRIBE
OPERATES YOU UNDER FORTY NINE
MACHINES AT THE RARE CASINO IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY.
WHICH IS NEAR THE SALTON SEA OUR
NEW COMPACT WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CLASS THREE GAMING
MACHINES THAT WE MAY OPERATE.
UP -- TO
TWELVE HUNDRED MACHINES OUR
PLANS --
MISTER REALIZE LATEST YOU COULD
SKIP TALKED --
SECOND LARGER FACILITY IN THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY NEAR THE CITY
OF THERMAL.
AND WITH THIS --
FACILITY LOCATED MUCH CLOSER TO
THE POPULATION CENTER.
THEN WE WILL ANTICIPATE REVENUES
WILL IN SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
WE HAVE A CRITICAL.
HARM SHORTAGE OF HOUSING AND THE
RESERVATION OPPORTUNITIES ARE
SCARCE SO ON RESERVATION
EMPLOYMENT IS CRITICAL TO OUR
MEMBERSHIP.
WE DISSIPATE THAT THE NEW GAMING
FACILITY WILL GENERATE JOBS NOT
ONLY FOR OUR TRIBAL MEMBERSHIP.
BUT ALSO THE SURROUNDING CITIES
OF THERMAL COACHELLA INDIO AND
THE ENTIRE COACHELLA VALLEY.
WE HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
THESE COMMITTEES WITH THESE
COMMUNITIES AND THEY HAVE ALWAYS
SUPPORTED OUR EFFORTS TO OPEN A
NEW GAMING FACILITY.
MANY GENERATIONS OF OUR PEOPLE
HAVE KNOWN NOTHING BUT POVERTY
BUT TODAY WE HAVE GREAT HOPE
THAT THIS HEARING.
IS A STEP TOWARD CHANGING THAT.
FOR NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS
OF MY TRIBE.
THIS NEW COMPACT REPRESENTS OUR
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BETTER FUTURE.
AND FOR HUG AND FOR CRITICAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES SUCH AS
EDUCATION AND HEALTHCARE.
SO IN SUMMARY I WOULD.
IT IS MY SINCERE HOPE THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT AND APPROVED A NEW
TOWARD MARTINEZ TRIBAL STATE
COMPACT.
AND THE HOPE THAT A REPRESENTS
FOR OUR TRIBE.
SO AGAIN I DO THINK OUR COMPACT
NEGOTIATION TEAM.
INCLUDING MISTER JOE DEL AND
THEIR CALIFORNIA TRIBAL BUSINESS
ALLIANCE PARA CONSULTANT AND
AMANDA --
CHRIS LINDSTROM SO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK.
THIS AFTERNOON AND PLEASE LET ME
KNOW IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
DRIVEN JACK.
JACK RIVEN WITH YOU UNITE HERE
THE HOTEL AND CASINO WORKERS
UNION IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
WE SUPPORT THE TORIES WATCHING
HIS BAND OF CAHUILLA INDIANS --
COMPACT AND A UNANIMOUS VOTE FOR
THEIR COMPACT THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME.
SUSAN JENSEN ON BEHALF OF SCENE
I GET IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS LINDSTROM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL BUSINESS
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEACHERS IN SUPPORT.
THE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING ABOUT THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE CONGRADULATIONS.
CHAIRMAN AND WILL LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THIS PARTY OF FOUR FOR
A FORMAL VOTE THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS BRINGS US TO
THE LAST ITEM ON OUR AGENDA
TWENTY NINE POUNDS.
COMPACT AND MISTER DILLON PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR COMMENTS AND
WILL WELCOME --
STEVE COLLEGE OUR TRIBAL CFO TO
THE DIES FOR COMMENTS YEAH THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN TRYING PALM SPEND
--
HAS.
REALLY TO GAINING FACILITIES ONE
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHEN IT'S
AMBER DO YOU KNOW BOTH --
TAKE TOGETHER OPERATE AROUND TWO
THOUSAND SLOTS THAT THE COMPACT
--
BEFORE YOU WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
GROW TED THREE THOUSAND AND FOUR
FACILITIES OF THE TWO NEW
FACILITIES.
I WOULD BE LIMITED TO HAVE NO
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED GAMING
DEVICES.
THAT --
GROWTH WOULD KICK IN IN THE
MIDDLE OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
OTHER TRIBES PAYMENT OBLIGATION.
UP UNTIL THEN TO ALLOW THE TRIED
TO RAMP UP TO EXPLORE
OPPORTUNITIES --
FOR THE MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE LAID OUT IN
THE CREDITS --
UP UNTIL THEN THE TRIBE PAY ITS
STF.
AND TWO MILLION TO THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FOR TRAVEL NATION
GRANT FUND WITH THE WITH THE
CREDIT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS EXPLICITLY FOR PAYMENTS
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
BEYOND THAT POINT ABOUT THE
TRIBE PAY 6% OR 7% OF NET NGUYEN
INTO THE RCF TGF DEPENDING ON
WHETHER THEY WERE THE LOW TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED ARE UP --
TO THREE THOUSAND WITH CREDITS
OF 60% FOR THE SAME KINDS OF
THINGS YOU SEEN OTHER.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE --
AS YOU MENTION MY NAME IS STEVE
THE TRIBALS THE TRIBE'S CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER.
AND I'M SORRY THAT CHAIRMAN
DARRELL MIKE IS UNABLE TO MAKE
THE HEARING TODAY --
THE TRIBE WANTS TO THANK GOD
CHAU SARIN JENNIFER AND THEIR
STAFF FURTHER THEIR HARD WORK
AND OTHER ASSOCIATES --
DOES THIS THIS A NEW COMPACT
GIVE CERTAINTY TO THE TRIBE FOR
THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS AS TO
WHAT THE THE RULES ARE.
AND IT IT ALLOWS THE THE TRIBE
TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE NINE
GAME IN LIMITED GAMING TRIBES
WHICH IS IMPORTANT OF COURSE --
ALSO IT'S IMPORTANT --
THIS WILL ALLOW THE TRIED TO
CONTINUE TO EMPLOY AND PICK
BENEFITS TO SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
EMPLOYEES --
AND THEIR AND THEIR FAMILIES --
WILL GIVE THE TRIBE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE THEIR TRIBAL GOVERNMENT
--
IN THAT OFFICE PROGRAMS AND
BENEFITS OF TO THE TRIBAL
MEMBERS --
IT'LL CONTINUE THE TRIBES COULD
WORK IN THEIR COMMUNITIES --
VIA.
CHARITABLE.
A CONTRIBUTIONS AND VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE WITH THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I JACK REMAIN WITH UNITE HERE --
WE URGE YOU TO YOU KNOW VOTE
UNANIMOUSLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
TWENTY NINE PALMS BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS --
COMPACT AMENDMENT --
AND AGAIN WE WANT TO SAY AT THE
END OF THE GOVERNOR BROWN
ADMINISTRATION WITH ALL THE
HARDWARE FROM JO JO IN THAT --
THIS IS REALLY BEEN A VERY VERY
GOOD EXPERIENCE FOR ALL IN MY
OPINION AND THANK YOU ALL OF
YOU.
FOR PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE AS WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
SUSAN JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF SCENE
I GET IN SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT.
OKAY WILL BRING ABOUT THE
MEMBERS --
FOR QUESTIONS ALL KICK IT OFF --
BASKING RIDGE DO IF HE MIGHT
GIVE US AN UPDATE ON THE RST
HALF.
GEN STF FUNDS --
GREAT QUESTION CHAIRMAN I DON'T
HAVE THE THE NUMBERS --
AT MY FINGERTIPS LIKE IT'S ONLY
PROVIDE THAT TO STAFF BUT I
THINK THAT --
THE BOTH FUNDS HERE AND A GOOD
POSITION I THINK THE COMMISSION
REPORTED OUT --
DURING THE BUDGET PROCESS ON THE
STATUS OF THE ARTS TF AND IT
LOOKED LIKE A BELIEVE AT THAT
TIME THAT THERE WOULD BE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS --
IN EXCESS OF THE ROUGHLY EIGHTY
MILLION THAT WAS REQUIRED TO
MEET THE OBLIGATIONS THE SEVENTY
TWO RCF ELIGIBLE TRIBES THAT.
ADDITIONAL MONEY WOULD UP FORM
THE BASIS OF WHAT --
WOULD BE IN THAT TRIBAL NATION
GRANT FUND --
THE BILL THAT YOUR AUTHORING I
BELIEVE GOT OUT OF THE SENATE IS
HEADED TO THE ASSEMBLY --
NOW SO --
THAT FUND IS IN A GOOD PLACE THE
STF LIKEWISE I THINK --
EXCEEDS ITS OBLIGATIONS BY.
I THINK SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS
IN TERMS OF WHERE THE FUND IS
CURRENTLY AT I THINK THE MOST
RECENT APPROPRIATIONS.
OF WITH TO COVER THE COSTS OF
THE THE STATE GAMING AGENCY AND
AND THAT THE COMMISSIONTHE
BUREAU IN IN THOSE ENTITIES THAT
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
IMPLEMENTATION THE COMPACTS AND
PROBLEM GAMBLING.
WAS ROUGHLY THIRTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS I THINK THE STATUS OF
THE FUND IS IS NOT THE FORTY
WE'VE NEGOTIATED COMPACTS THAT.
FOR THE MOST PART USING A PRO
RATA FORMULA --
SOME THE LARGER TRIED TO PAYING
MORE THAN THEIR SHARE --
AND SO I I THINK THAT AS WE LOOK
OUT IS ALWAYS HARD TO TELL
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
FUTURE BUT IT LOOKS LIKE THOSE
FUNDS THAT FUND WILL BE IN A IN
A GOOD POSITION GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANY --
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
WELL IN CONCLUDING AROUND
[inaudible]
THE SCHOOL.
JUST WAVING HELLO.
MR DEL AND THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR ALL OF YOUR WORK YOU'VE
KEPT YOUR A PERFECT RECORD AND
TRACK OF BRINGING ES COMPAQ'S
EARLY AND OFTEN IN THIS SESSION.
AND NOT WAITING TILL THE FINAL
WEEKS OF AUGUST [inaudible]
BOB.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS WE
APPRECIATE.
THEIR WONDERFUL WORKING
RELATIONSHIP OUR COMMITTEE HAS
HAD -- WITH
YOU AT YOUR OFFICE IN THE OFFICE
THE GOVERNOR.
ON THIS HAS BEEN AS MISTER
GIBBONS SAID A AN EXCEPTIONAL
PROCESSING DOT ACT ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED.
AND DUH INTAKE YOU FOR YOUR WORK
AND IT'S BEEN A REAL PLEASURE --
I KNOW SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CHAIRMAN THERE'S BEEN A REAL
PLEASURE.
TO WORK WITH THE AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FEEL THE SAME.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THAT MEANS A
LOT IT'S REALLY BEEN MY PLEASURE
WHAT WITH ALL OF YOU AND YOUR
STAFF.
CONGRATULATIONS AND WE'LL SEE
THIS ON THE FOR FOR A VOTE IN
SHORT ORDER.
WITH THAT THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING TODAY THANK YOU